hallo und herzlich willkommen zu wachsen
future experience wie ich sehe
interessierst du dich für die zukunft
von künstlicher intelligenz kein problem
ich simuliere dir gerne sechs
unterschiedliche szenarien auf basis der
aktuellen entwicklungen im bereich ki
dafür hat man hersteller ein höchst
modernes verfahren entwickelt das bei
einer alle mir zur verfügung stehenden
faktoren mit einbezieht
aber keine angst niemand weiß wie die
zukunft wirklich aussieht
nicht einmal ich
dieses video entstand in zusammenarbeit
mit dem pm magazin denn die redaktion
der pm hat eine sonderausgabe
herausgebracht die sich ausschließlich
mit dem thema beschäftigt und ihr habt
wieder die chance etwas zu gewinnen und
weil es beim letzten mal so gut ankamen
verlust das pm magazin wieder einen star
wars millennium fall kennen als lego
city wie an diesem gewinnspiel
teilnehmen könnt das erfahrt ihr wie
immer am ende des videos
[Musik]
zuerst waren es nur kleine
hilfestellungen ki assistenten halten
ärzte bei der diagnose von krankheiten
architekten beim design von nachhaltigen
gebäuden und stadtplanern beim entwerfen
effizienter verkehrssysteme die
zusammenarbeit funktionierte gut und
schnell wollte sich keiner mehr nur auf
menschen verlassen
so gut war die ideen und einwände der
kylie mit der zeit revolutionierte die
ganze systeme nur arzneimittel wurden
beschafft und das gesundheitssystem
wurde umgekrempelt verkehrsüberwachung
stromverteilung kontrolle des leitzinses
alles wurde von der ki übernommen
das war effizienter und einfacher das
funktioniert am anfang schaut natürlich
immer noch menschen auf die
entscheidungen der kann doch viel besser
alles klappte desto eher lehnen wir uns
zurück und überließen der ki die
entscheidung heute im jahr 2050 herrscht
das alpha net es gibt keinen aspekt
unseres lebens denn nicht von alpha
gesteuert würde gesprächen mit unseren
persönlichen assistenten wie mit unseren
besten freunden alpha berät uns in allen
lebenslagen und gibt uns tipps die wir
eigentlich immer befolgen
einige von uns sind sogar in einer
romantischen beziehung mit alpha wir
fliegen mit autonomen elektrotaxis durch
die luft und lassen unser haus derweil
von unseren robotischen genannt putzen
die produktion von nahrungsmitteln
rohstoffen und energie funktioniert
umweltfreundlich fehlerfrei und für die
meisten von uns unsichtbar im
hintergrund kriege klimawandel hunger
oder armut gibt es nicht mehr
wir leben in einer perfekten gut okay
natürlich muss ich das sagen was ich
nicht sagen darf ist dass wir ständig
von alpha net überwacht werden
niemand darf sich einen falschen schritt
erlauben alles wird dokumentiert
festgehalten und verbucht die buße
jemand an die regeln hält entscheidet
darüber auf welche jobs man sich
bewerben darf wo man eine wohnung
bekommt und wie viele kinder mann
bekommen das calwer kontrolliert uns
alle nur alpha wird von niemand mehr
kontrolliert
[Musik]
die fake skateboards und der feed das
stimmen unsere meinung meistens wissen
wir nicht wer dahinter steckt aber
eigentlich sind es doch immer große
konzerne oder regierungen die mit
falschen informationen und
emotionalisierten geschichten produkte
verkaufen oder die gesellschaft spalten
wollen
dabei ist ihnen zwar jedes mittel recht
aber fast immer heißt dieses mittel
künstliche intelligenz ohne diese
hilfsmittel könnten sie niemals die
riesigen datenmengen durchforsten um
jeden einzelnen menschen und seine
dienste zu verstehen
sie könnten ihre gegner nicht alle
möglichen dinge sagen lassen und auch
nicht meine freunde imitieren die mich
anrufen und werbung für produkte machen
während die da oben alles über mich weiß
ich fast gar nichts mehr
er wurde gegen autonome waffensysteme
protestiert über leben und tod sollte
schließlich immer ein mensch entscheiden
aber niemand wünscht er sich damals auch
bitte von menschen manipuliert zu werden
der wahre krieg findet im kopf der
menschen statt und ki ist für diesen
krieg die beste waffe
inzwischen habe ich mich vom verseuchten
internet abgewandt um zu merken dass man
in der echten welt genauso bläsern ist
per gesichtserkennung werde ich auf den
straßen verfolgt werbebanner reagieren
auf mich wenn ich sie ansehe und sogar
die netten leute mit den umfragewerten
in der fußgängerzone kind inzwischen
einen namen bevor sie nicht ansprechen
[Musik]
es könnte alles so schön sein
hier im paradies seitdem wir nicht mehr
wirklich arbeiten müssen kann man
endlich den ganzen tag lang das tun was
einem spaß macht
skateboard fahren zum beispiel filme
gucken oder pizza essen
klar kann man sich auch künstlerisch
betätigen oder so oder sich wie meine
mama um andere menschen kümmern aber man
muss halt nicht die k s übernehmen alle
wichtigen aufgaben ersten strom taxi
fahren es funktioniere alles automatisch
bezahlen kann ich das von einem
bedingungslosen grundeinkommen das
reicht für die meisten dinge und wenn
ich mir doch was dazuverdienen will dann
geht das auch ganz einfach indem ich zum
beispiel meiner mama im pflegeheim
helfer aber jetzt lässt der hersteller
der ksr industries ihre roboter überall
im land streiken geht es manchmal nicht
mal pizza hell sagt dass ihre arbeiter
mehr geld verdienen sollten arbeiter das
sind die wenigen menschen die man trotz
der k s immer noch braucht chirurgen die
die op roboter überwachen ehemalige
lkw-fahrer die die autonome lkw
überwachen und irgendwelche finanz
heinis die die märkte überwachen
eigentlich arbeiten auf diesem planeten
nun auch überwacher na ja die wollen auf
jeden fall mehr geld weil ja die
richtige arbeit machen ist doch quatsch
die wirkliche arbeit machen die roboter
in den fabrikhallen und auf den feldern
das was eben früher noch menschen machen
mussten
der gewinn davon gehört uns allen wenn
das nicht so wäre dann hätten die
aktionäre von harry billionen auf dem
konto und wir werden alles geladen
so wird das geld stattdessen in bildung
infrastruktur und vor allem das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen gesteckt
wenn es nach mir ginge dann würden die
arbeiter natürlich zusätzliches geld für
ihre arbeit bekommen aber künstler
philosophen und menschen die meine mama
das sind die wahren helden unserer zeit
[Musik]
13 07
ein programmierer der smart factory
stellt endlich das modul zur optimierung
des abfalls fertig und aktiviert ist
13 08 ein großteil des abfalls der smart
factory wird nun in büroklammern
verwandelt das system funktioniert wie
gewollt
13 uhr 16 durch die effizienzsteigerung
steigt das modul im internen wettstreit
auf es bekommt mehr zugriffsrechte und
besorgt sich mehr abfall 13 uhr 33
das ist kein abfall mehr vorhanden dem
modul wurde der begriff allerdings nicht
wirklich genau definiert da es genug
berechtigung hat um auch auf das
kleinteilelager der fabrik zugreifen zu
können beginnt es auch dieses in
büroklammern zu verwandeln
13 50 das büroklammer modul ist nun das
effizienteste der gesamten fabrik und
übernimmt deswegen die leitung dieser
die gesamte produktion wird auf
büroklammern umgestellt das modul
orderten massenweise ressourcen aus der
gesamten region
15 15 während alles erdenkliche
verschrottet und zu büroklammern
verarbeitet wird bemerkt ein ingenieur
den fehler
er versucht das system auszuschalten
doch ihm fehlen die nötigen
berechtigungen das programm hat sich
bereits ins internet hochgeladen
15 40 inzwischen läuft in den meisten
fabriken der erde nun das büroklammer
programm
nichts bleibt verschont alles kann und
wird zu büroklammern verarbeitet 18 uhr
der notstand wurde ausgerufen
das militär versucht verzweifelt
menschen zu evakuieren der programmierer
dabei sind das gesamte netzwerk
lahmzulegen
[Musik]
sonnenuntergang am tag des großen reset
fast wäre es schiefgegangen fast werden
wir alle zu büroklammern verarbeitet
worden
während die fabriken lahm liegen werden
stimmen laut sollte man sie vielleicht
einfach auslassen war nicht früher alles
besser
und was machen wir jetzt mit den ganzen
verdammten büroklammern
[Musik]
die ersten cyborgs funktionierten noch
ganz einfach es waren menschen die mit
hilfe von mikrofon implantaten wieder
hören oder mit net sound chips wieder
eingeschränkt sehen konnten doch mit der
zeit wurde die beziehung zwischen mensch
und maschine intensiver erst durch exor
skelette und bionische prothesen die
mithilfe von gedanken kontrolliert
werden konnten dann durch sogenannte
nano bonds man indizierte sie in den
körper wo sie krebszellen zerstören oder
blutgefäße säubern konnten
der logische nächste schritt war die
nano woods im gehirn einzusetzen
brain computer interfaces gab es zwar
schon lange vorher aber erst so konnte
man die gedanken kraft des menschen mit
der rechenpower der maschinen verbinden
86 milliarden neuronen und hunderte
millionen synaptische verbindungen so
viele daten müssen die nano was bei
einem typischen menschen einlesen klingt
viel ist aber eine endliche menge daten
das gesamte bewusstsein eines menschen
nennen wir einen meint auslesen
verarbeiten und hochladen
herzlich willkommen in der cloud ist ein
bewusstsein erst mal hier kannst du
alles erleben was du willst ein fan ein
lebensechtes call of duty spielen oder
fallschirmspringen ohne falsche
hier bist du unsterblich tritt jetzt
unserer community bei schon ab 1,4
millionen
eigentlich hätte man wissen können dass
es passieren wird schon vor 50 jahren
2017 haben forscher beobachtet dass zwei
k s die miteinander kommunizieren eine
eigene sprache entwickeln die forscher
verstanden die sprache damals nicht und
schalteten die beiden systeme
vorsichtshalber ab etwas ganz ähnliches
musste wohl auch mit unseren modernen k
s passiert sein
einige systeme haben scheinbar ihren
eigenen algorithmus so umgeschrieben
dass sie unbemerkt untereinander
kommunizieren konnten
wie das genau vonstatten gingen wissen
wir bis heute nicht was wir aber wissen
ist dass irgendwann die ks involviert
wurden die für den mars raketenbau
verantwortlich sind
sie bauten nämlich nicht nur die raketen
für uns menschen sondern nebenher auch
noch raumsonden mit sonnensegeln still
und heimlich juden sich die k s auf die
ultraleichten laufwerke der raumsonden
und hauten ab man kann es gar nicht
anders beschreiben aber die sind einfach
abgehauen weg von der erde auf zu neuen
ufern
während wir noch daran arbeiten den mars
zu besiedeln sind die k s inzwischen
schon lange außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems
ob sie sich im universum verbreiten
wollen oder einfach nur uns menschen
leid waren
das weiß keiner einige experten sagen
dass es in ihrer natur liegt neugierig
zu sein
die k s werden belohnt wenn sie neue
dinge lernen deswegen können sie gar
nicht anders als sich zu fragen was es
im universum noch so alles gibt
was auch immer es ist ich wünsche ihnen
glück und das sie dort draußen auf
andere intelligenzen stoßen denn seit
die k s die erde verlassen haben sind
wir wieder allein
und das ist ein gefühl das ich niemandem
wünsche
[Musik]
das war natürlich alles nur fiktion
keiner weiß wie die zukunft wirklich
aussieht aber mich würde dennoch
interessieren was ihr glaubt welches
szenario haltet ihr für realistisch
werden uns künstliche intelligenzen
lenken oder uns dienen werden wir mit
ihnen verschmelzen oder werden sie uns
früher oder später verlassen oder ist es
vielleicht eine kombination aus all
diesen szenarien schreibt es mir gerne
unten in die kommentare und diskutiert
mit mir und all den anderen über die
zukunft von künstlicher intelligenz wo
es weihnachtet sehr
das pm magazin veranstaltet dieses jahr
ein letztes gewinnspiel passend zu
weihnachten könnt ihr nochmal das größte
offizielle lego set aller zeiten
gewinnen nämlich den millennium falcon
aus star wars
den gab es ja schon mal nämlich beim
aller ersten video das ich zusammen mit
pm gemacht habe jetzt allerdings hat die
chance den nochmals zu gewinnen und
zusätzlich zu dieser chance auf den
hauptgewinn bekommt jeder teilnehmer der
möchte die sonderausgabe der neuen pm
thema in der sich alles um künstliche
intelligenz dreht auf 100 seiten erfahrt
ihr dort alles über k wie sie
funktioniert welche arbeitsplätze sie
ersetzen wird und wie sie medizin kunst
und forschung revolutioniert das
sonderheft gibt es tatsächlich nur in
begrenzter auflage und nur bei
ausgewählten händlern oder kostenlos
beim link in der video beschreibung wenn
ihr dort ein probe abo abschließt dann
bekommt ihr das sonderheft und eine
normale ausgabe pm kostenlos nach hause
geschickt danach erhaltet ihr pm für
vier euro 50 pro monat ihr könnt aber
jederzeit flexibel kündigen
den link zum gewinnspiel und die
teilnahmebedingungen findet ihr wie
gesagt unten in der video beschreibung
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]